Gary thank you so much for making time
and it's a pleasure to meet you here in
New York now to introduce your next
lecture that you will give on the 21st
of March I have some questions you chose
the topic timeless values in a shifting
world why this topic my name is topic is
important at any time because we're
talking about timeless values that the
issue of values becomes even more
important as a time when the human race
is at the nexus where you have to choose
the path for the future and if you miss
it if you make rotor you know then the
cost for rectify this mistake could be
too high and highly think that after the
end of the Cold War the victor remainder
the free world complacent and nearly 25
years have been wasted without having
you know proper comprehensive
discussions about the future the future
build on our values the values that made
the free world successful the values
help the free world to win the Cold War
and pretending that these values can
change with the changing world it's
doing a great service for the core core
foundation for civilization so I want to
talk about geopolitical picture but
always refer to the values that made the
successful free wall possible what is it
that drives you where is your political
commitment coming from no I was believed
that my duty as you know of any decent
your game is to contributing time energy
resources to make a difference and I
fell that I could make the difference
first in chess and now I think I could
take don't maybe not as huge
contributions in the game of chess but
still significant contribution for this
world to understand the nature of the
challenges were facing and rational ways
of dealing with these problems and
looking in the future because somehow it
correlates was what i did a chair at
chess board by analyzing the games
looking for mistakes and preparing for
future battles yeah in 1972 alexander
solzhenitsyn add his Nobel speech and I
would like to quote him he says the
spirit of Munich is in no sense no sense
a thing of the past for that was no
flash in the pan I would go so far as to
say that the spirit of Munich is the
dominant one in the 20th century the
spirit of Munich is an illness of the
willpower of the well-to-do it is the
usual state of those who have
surrendered to the list for comfort at
any price they've surrendered to
materialism is the main aim of our life
on Earth end of quote I think you agree
with this right absolutely the situation
answer to was different but these wars
can completely applied to the current
situation in the forms of Union and
actually to other challenges that the
free world is facing yes you agree with
him right so then the question is how
come he says is in 1972 you say equal
things nowadays how come that in the
20th century and a 21st century the
West's is still under the spell of the
spirit of Munich yeah let's let's be
very clear this is not a linear
progression yes there was a medic yes
there was Chamberlain who followed by
was
ocean and then there was a yellow
conference were you know under pressure
from Stalin so Churchill and Roosevelt
mainly rural agreed to soar give up part
of Europe because probably very hard to
resist pressure from the dominance of
army accountant but then there was Heric
Truman who defended the world who saved
was you who saved high one who saves
South Korea and it was a long as you
know like in its black and white I must
say black and white it's just you know
it's the different periods net 1972 was
not a good period it was a period where
the free world was on retreats beds
eight years later Ronald Reagan and it
was the counter-attack that ended up
with a triumphant victory with the fall
of the Berlin Wall eventually fall of
communism and collapse of the Soviet
Union naturally after big victory
complacency joy let's celebrate and we
forgot that a disappearance Berlin Wall
and collapse elusive Union did not mean
the end of our fight against evil evil
survives he will change its forms but
the challenges are always there history
cannot end as was predicted by Francis
Fukuyama there's no end of history
history seasonal that's why I'm coming I
was a book windows windows coming
because its season it's it repeats
itself as Munich are in 1938 or some are
repeated in early 70s ribosomes nitzan
reflected now but I've no doubt that the
strengths of our civilization that
helped us to to reach the position where
we are now and whether the first time in
the history of human race democracies
the free world is much more powerful
than all the enemies combined there is
the total domination militarily
politically financially but it also
creates
a psychological challenge because people
who are so comfortable with their lives
they have no appetite they're not
stocked go for wars and conflicts and
they they tend to resist any calls to
their duties but again at one point they
recognized that the challenge is
imminent and it doesn't go away and the
combinational factor as well mobilize
the free world wants it again to defeat
its enemies but do you already see new
truants or Reagan's are people standing
up no I don't see nutriments Reagan's in
this country knit in Europe but I
believe there is a huge potential that
will reveal very quickly because the
cycle of replacing politicians today is
much quicker you have so many means of
communication that coup de niro build
and ruin reputations and information
travels fast so the moment the public
realizes the public in uniting the
United States and United Kingdom and
France and Germany Holland the moment
probably believes that the free world
must present a very strong sufficient
response to the threats coming from
Putin from al-qaeda from Isis from all
sorts of [ __ ] who are threatening our
to destroy the values of civilization
I'm sure democracies always provides its
paladins there will be warriors that
will be called by the public Betty and I
think it will take almost no time well
your electric vehicle to be to the
public to take up arms and write my
lecture will be an attempt to explain
why this threat that we're facing today
is existential and we don't have to
waste time as would eat in the series or
in the 60s or 70
wait for the day of do so due to wait
for the sweat to become real attestation
you don't have to prove it to everybody
you know who has no interest in politics
you don't want it I'll German bombs
dropped to London so as you don't want
to know Soviet saw the troops in
Afghanistan and and the world at the
edge of nuclear pact ellipses you'd
better deal with the problem when the
cost of solving this problem is still
not extremely high and and I will be
communicating this message to people in
the audience and way beyond is what is
that this is not a simple response to
military threats or in a political
maneuver juice or outsmart Putin's of
this well this is a very important
moment for us to lay down the vision for
the future the future that will be built
upon the values at NATO successful um
you know this famous quote of this
French conservative philosopher shows
after the massacre he said he must have
said every nation gets the government
leaders it deserves now the Russians
with it's gigantic cultural heritage the
tools toys that the damn all the dancers
and the musicians the poets matter fact
Gary casado science to appear we have
science from space with space race
against fresh yet these are putting okay
what about German heritage you know
philosophy science music I mean you name
it and then Hitler darling books it
seems to me that almost every nations or
mini nations news
no madness and what we are facing today
in Russia is the ultimate power of this
propaganda machine that could turn
millions of people into zombie even
despite alternatives also information
available it's hard to resist such
pressure with 24 7 propaganda machine
that has been working on the orals
principles the war is peace slavery is
freedom it's a complete lie and many
people simply couldn't believe that such
why can they come sort of a permanent
guest or just it's not only guest you
know it's it totally occupied Russian
airspace I think it's it's temporary I
think it just it will go away this again
it happened before history it will
happen this time in Russia the problem
is not what will have to excuse he will
end up as a rat in one go that's no
doubt about it that's the that's what
happens with guys looking the problem is
what price Russia Ukraine for most of
human and the entire world will pay for
Putin's madness because unlike Hitler he
has his finger on the nuclear button and
that's why I'm calling for decisive
actions today as I called yesterday day
before yesterday because from history I
know I know that one simple things they
lessen that who can learn even if they
need the price of confronting dictator
today and dangerous dictator Michael hi
and if the even the consequences may be
very
potentially dangerous tomorrow the price
goes up and the day after tomorrow the
price will go and hire so sooner we
confront this dictator and to confront
me today we must we could recognize it's
inevitable because his algorithm of
staying power includes conflict within
Russia outside of Russia and in
neighboring countries and also was the
rest of the world because that's the
only way to prove his uniqueness
invincibility for Russian public to keep
up millions tens of millions of people
in the zombie status you have to sort of
raise the stakes all the time you have
to keep bluffing with very weak hand in
poker but keep bluffing certain even
with nuclear Armageddon to scare of your
opponents so we have no choice and again
this is not simple you know fight
between us and them this is a fight
between civilization that is responsible
for most of great things happen on this
planet and we must protect it and we
must do it remembering about these great
timeless values that made the success of
the civilization possible my final
question your lecture is very political
philosophical also know these are not
particularly thinks young students
nowadays are very much interested in why
would you urge especially young students
to come to the lecture I think I will
tell you a few interesting things so it
just it's um I was always curious to
hear people and that's something to say
I think that I can present it a
constantly informed the very important
ideas for them to think of I'm not sort
of laying down my vision for the future
or telling them this is the only Road
that they have to choose but I want
people to
thing I want them to become active again
I think it's very important to
revitalize democracy by bringing people
in democracy is not for people in
Washington Berlin Paris Hague random
democracies for everybody to be active
and there we have unique opportunities
now with all these communications
techniques with new technologies to get
our message straight to the 22 22 22 the
desks of those who are making decisions
and I will begin also addressing the
audience specially young audience asking
them to become active not to wait before
crisis comes to you think use the
technology use the experience that could
be accumulated from reading the books
and also again collecting this data for
internet predict this crisis see the
problem before it becomes too too too
big and addresses again democracy is
it's a very vibrant thing it's just it's
it's it survives and it flourishes when
people are actively engaged it's about
using the power the wisdom of the crowd
and that's only one one of them one of
my messages because it's also part of
the timeless values Gary thank you so
much for this interview and all of us
are very much looking forward to your
lecture on 21st of March you very soon
you